[Music]  christina aguillera  dishes on Ryan Gosling during James  Corden's carpool karaoke primetime  special I think so I think so the 37  year old singer hit the streets with the  late-night host during Monday night's  episode where she shared a bit more than  her incredible vocals now you were in  the Mickey Mouse Club with the most  incredible group of cast mates who was  in that Mickey Mouse Club with you it  was me it was Britney it was Justin it  was Ryan Gosling Gosling even then that  age could you find yourself getting lost  in Ryan Gosling's eyes I know Ryan  actually pretty much he did up a push on  Britney X Tina also taught James how to  belt out her iconic growl that's other  special guests included Melissa McCarthy  [Applause]  have been here the entire time and an  epic rewind moment from Ed Sheeran's  turn sitting shotgun cuz I was ablaze I  saw  to say you know was on the drink maybe I  misspoke  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]